but you had a good time it's great but
it's not like vegas vegas no it's it's
so wise guys we're talking about wise
guys guys vegas yeah is in the arts
district they put a billion dollars down
so you don't feel like you're over it
and like not at all dude
that room mark my words that that that
wise guys is going to be a great club in
vegas because it's small but the the
the acoustics
though they're so loud and incredible
it's so so i've been when that laughter
hits it's like it's unbelievable i
forgot
when you got a room like that that's
made of concrete the way keith stubbs
who and paulie short
but the way they designed it is is going
to be sick oh i think that's good this
will be one of the more fun clubs it's
like an old-school small
club 150 people 200 people but it's
it's gonna be great that's like the
perfect size
i think so yo i did something
that i've never done before and it was
terrifying yeah i got called in to do a
table read and i guess like
it doesn't mean like i have a part i
think they just wanted me to
read and the people that i had to sign
an nda and [ __ ] but i can tell you like
basics
and um the table read is when you have a
script and all the actors sit around
with the director you hear it out loud
right and all the producers and and the
actors read the script out loud so the
writers producers and director can hear
it out loud in their heads so that's
called a table read yeah so the writers
of this pretty
well known
and but they knew me because of my
comedy i guess they had seen footage
right
and
so they reached out and were like yo we
want you to come read for this part
and i'm and i get there
because i was like i don't know what
this is i don't know i was like why the
hell you call me i was like i've never
done it like what are you what are you
doing
and i'm around
pros sure pros like well-known actors
and actresses
ryan so i'm sitting there i even brought
my glasses everyone right listen i got
glasses from her sister and i haven't
worn those things since i walked out the
damn uh
uh
so yeah since i walked out the place i
even forget what it's called
and i started to get a headache
right because when you get new glasses
you're supposed to like wear them your
eyes like the muscles start [ __ ] i
started getting a headache then i
started getting a panic attack
and i was i was getting nauseous
and one of the biggest actors
in the game right is like right next to
me
and i'm like freaking the [ __ ] out
no and they're filming it
they're filming it yeah they do and it's
front of all these execs yeah from this
big big ass you didn't think to call
daddy
i was i should have come i should have i
can help you with these things i should
have read it together
but don't call me because i don't know
anything about that i've never done a
table read
what do i know about acting you know
what though here's the thing i've only
i've been doing it for 27 years it's
like it's like brandon never having me
look at his special like it's all right
i don't know go with go with schultz and
and the stefano go with the guys that
have been doing it for i don't know 10
years i know they've been really good
and they've gotten really successful but
don't go with me because i don't think
about comedy i don't think about the
actual process and how to write i don't
know
i don't i don't
never
all you [ __ ] forget but it's
i'm just the old guy so i'm always like
i just sit there and shake my head and i
go okay
great i don't yeah you're right i have
no idea
it was terrifying though
like when i started to freak out and i
had to like keep my cool yeah i can help
you with those things
yeah yes i've had to overcome those
things myself that's why i can help you
the reason i can the reason i'm the
world heavyweight champion at
understanding that behavior and helping
yes and helping other people navigate it
is because i've been as deep as you can
get and it's so crazy it's it was cool
it was fun
very different yeah
very but i actually liked it i actually
had a good time and you did it and
you'll be better the next time yeah yeah
yeah but it was yeah i i was literally
nauseous oh yeah dude when i got there i
walked in i didn't realize all these
well-known actors were going to be doing
this table read and i'm sitting here and
i'm in a corner by myself
eating my
vegan sandwich that they got me from
this vegan
restaurant i didn't know what to say to
anybody because i was like i don't know
i've done table reads where ben siller
and owen wilson are right there and
we're doing scenes together i've done
i've done i did i read an entire script
where all my scenes which were with tom
cruise in a room with six other people
but he and i are doing we're acting
together and i better you better be on
point that's what i'm saying i'm just
like i'm with tom cruise right now and
i'm acting with him in a room like it
was just so surreal that's why i was
like i was trying to figure out why this
dude he did like he's a big fan of my
comedy like he really loves my stand-up
and i was like okay but like
i've never done this well if you get the
part
see that's an audition but you didn't
know it
that's an audition no it ain't
look at me oh i'm telling you
okay
so
that was it
that was not that was not for you to
read that that was an audition
any time you do that and they're
shooting it that is 100 an audition
and i have seen many of people including
the people they had for the starring
role not get the part based off of that
so whenever they say we're just reading
it they're trying to keep they're
talking to it yeah it's an audition it's
fine but it's an audience all these damn
things on the script
okay
how do you think you did
oh they they said i did really really
good i bet you and i kind of like
blacked out because i was just you know
it was a comedy script you know and i
just read
it's like okay how how would you know
i read that i read the script beforehand
but i didn't read it as like my
character i read this script to read the
script all you gotta do is two things
what one is like set your intention
what's the intention what's going on
that quick right
when you've read the script when you
read the script yeah and you show your
character when you see who your
character is i'm getting a lot of
resistance
you set your intention in life there's
always an intention
always right now my intention is to
explain something to you my my job right
now what i'm trying to do is take all
the fear out of acting yeah and a table
because i want you to be successful
right so that's my intention is a
teacher or somebody who's older
and so everything is an intention in
life you you're always you're there's
something you want from the other person
on the scene and so once you figure that
out and that's what i would have helped
you with and then the rest is just
listen and answer don't worry take all
your attention away from yourself and
you just put it all on in front of the
person in front of you so you just
listen to them really the way you're
listening to me now yeah yeah that's all
you got to do and you see i went yeah
yeah you didn't think about yeah yeah
that's acting you just react acting is
real
they should call it reacting not acting
all right
class is over yeah one of the guys uh
the
well-known actor
he's like yeah i've done thousands of
these i was like this is my first one
that's great he was like he's like
really look where you've gotten look
where you are right now what do you mean
you came from you were a valet in cars
yeah when i met a valley alumni when i
met you you were valeting cars at the
andaz or whatever it's called uh no uh
the palomar the palomar in downtown
phoenix and you're you just did a
reading with [ __ ]
you know i'm telling you but you deserve
it that's where you're supposed to be oh
wait no i signed the nda it's where
you're supposed to be
it's where you're supposed to be yeah it
was cool though bring up um
i want to send you something that i i
[ __ ] it's five seconds but i i wait
so wait when you guys did
when you um
when you guys did mad tv you always did
table reads for your sketches i've never
done a tv show anytime we did the
goldberg school uh
anything i've ever done entourage
anything you always do a table read
that's a common thing because they write
a script right so they'll write a script
and then when it wasn't like they need
to hear it they need to hear it they
need to hear it because they go back for
notes they go back and do notes so they
see what it is and they go that didn't
work this didn't you don't you don't
know if something works until you can
you you hear it yeah yeah that's the
only way to do it okay i'm gonna send
this to chin what is it what are you
showing up um it's just something from
your weekend no my weekend i'll talk
about but this this was i mean vegas can
kiss my ass in general vegas is
aggressive it's just not inspired man
it's all sensation
do you know what i don't you know it's
all yeah it's like you're
so then you might ask yourself yeah
let me share it with you listen to this
i thought this was really really
beautiful are you philosophical
yeah but it's it's reminded me of what
you did you you left the comfort of
phoenix and you came here that takes
guts
and and part of what you went through is
beautiful because it's part of the the
journey but i just saw this and i just
thought this might be the philosophy of
life for me anyway and for my children
and for anybody who's speaking it jordan
peterson watch this [ __ ] watch this
watch so then you might ask yourself
well what's the best antidote to the
discomfort of life that's the bravery of
a mother to
allow that to happen but not only that
to to facilitate it so what about where
you go kid where you go where you go
well why it's dangerous out there it's
like yeah no kidding it's more dangerous
here if you stay with me so you might
lose your body out there in the world
but if you stay here you lose your soul
so then you might have damn that last
part
i love [ __ ] like that
i geek out horses that's the theme of
everybody i don't know much about him
that's this theme don't don't beat me up
if you guys all know about that
everybody should listen there but that's
the theme of every group has been
teaching us
that's the theme of every great story
yeah
if you're not interested in that okay
cool yeah that is it um
yeah i like that yeah i don't know it
just hit me in a way to where yeah well
i mean yeah it's the adventure you just
embrace it just come on yeah here we go
let's go [ __ ] yeah i'm going through all
this [ __ ] right now how much money i
moved ahead when i moved i know
i'm doing this right now i'm i'm going
out i'm doing a bunch of [ __ ] i'm not
gonna talk about but yeah it's scary but
it's good yeah yeah man it keeps me ooh
i love it
the only thing you know the only reason
why i moved to uh la's cause uh well
obviously you gave me like the
encouragement but uh my friend just
happened because i didn't decide on a
date right i decided when my friend was
like hey i heard you in talks of one and
eventually moved to l.a i had a room
that just opened up and i was like i'm
moving to l.a i love it that's literally
how i did it palsy
the newest member of thick boy right i
know i just talked across uh from uh
illinois right i forgot which the kids
lost 260 [ __ ] penny he's still going
yeah still [ __ ] going he's he's
that's special yeah yeah wow what a what
a good kid
yeah
come on man that's sick oh damn he's got
a new uh now that's a different george
harris ain't it no no
that's him don't do yeah i'm impressed
man yeah i'm impressed
yeah um
he's gonna be he's
that that's a special human being right
you have to you have to respect that
it's it's crazy when people
don't well dude you know dude and it's
mainly i think that mainly because those
other people are terrified to take those
kind of leaps so they kind of
you know look at him
i know look what he did he sat there
like he sat there this kid sat there and
lost 260 pounds and now he's in studio
smiling ear to ear
and actually has a job and doing [ __ ]
he's like like that's a bad [ __ ]
and what he's only what he's only 22.
yeah that's kind of that talk about
heroic like sometimes being a hero is
just getting out of your own [ __ ] way
it's like me at 22. i did not have that
[ __ ] mentality well i mean
i would probably die aggressive crazy
yeah you know
i'm ready to fight the world because i
think the world's against me are out to
give me oh oh it still is
oh oh oh it still is
hey the world's skillet i'm not saying
not to keep giving and loving no no no
no i know i know i know yes like just be
i'm [ __ ] rogue in the stock remember
he goes nobody cares i was i was i was
you know retired and my head was all
messed up my eye was real [ __ ] up but
nobody cares you know i thought
everyone's going to be waiting for me
but
everyone's doing their life what was i
supposed to do huh and then and and
rogan's laughing and it's like [ __ ]
hey yeah that's right yeah yeah that's
right nobody has to die no last time no
no no one has time for me i'm too busy
yeah
nobody gives a [ __ ] anyway okay i love
you but i got i got kids bro
that's pretty good gsp impressions yeah
i do
i got an ear for accents
but you know it's more more about
it
it's not french it's more stronger you
know he's from israel yeah he's from
montreal but his first language is
french because they're friends
yeah it's well they speak english and
french but in montreal parts of montreal
all they speak about all they do is is
french that's it but a lot of times they
don't necessarily have that the french
no they don't have a french that's why
i'm doing this it's strong i wish sweet
you see
they say it's not a good one but you
know
where it's you know if i'm from france
it's a bit more soft you know
it's completely it's completely
different
yes
remember that you used to do
where you spoke like a lot of french oh
when i was i had a street fight in
france yes i i've retired that but he
did this bit and it was a long bit
did you ever see a cat yeah i didn't
yeah oh you saw it yeah
where the whole
i did the whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
people loved it it's not stupid yeah it
was funny no it's actually it was
actually stupid here's my problem i'm
shooting my special may 19th by the way
you're gonna add that in here improv
a couple announcements before we start
joey diaz
oh yes guesting on my shows at stress
factory this weekend starting thursday
friday he hasn't gone up in a minute huh
i don't know but joey is going to be
there crushing it with me stress factory
get your tickets they're selling very
quickly yeah they're about to make an
announcement i'm going to post a thing
um
and then uh what was i talking about
before this cause i'm old stuff what
yeah
yeah my special i'm shooting that uh may
19th uh at bray improv crystalia coming
on
uh as my opener um but like i have like
i'm trying to whittle down what
bits because my some of these bits are
[ __ ]
crushing and i don't know and i think
i'm just going to do a list of [ __ ] of
topics and [ __ ] do that because it's
been
hitting do the two so hard
i'll do all of it man you do the dubai
yeah i'll do that because that fits in
nicely yeah i like the tuba dude i got
so much to do have you ever heard him
make a tuba noise it's kind of crazy
the [ __ ] he does on stage
as a comedian is [ __ ] like insane
yeah like the way you find like
i try i'm writing a lot right now i'm
right but like you understand what the
[ __ ] he's doing like the way he makes a
tuba look without necessarily having a
tuba using my body yeah he uses his body
i'm an animator like a [ __ ]
yeah tuba this is gonna be fun this is
gonna be like less philosophy and just
more [ __ ] hard hitting funny [ __ ]
because when you do a special i'm
realizing people just want to watch
funny don't preach to me [ __ ]
just yeah just make me laugh i feel that
same way
i just like [ __ ]
telling jokes in a goofy ass way like it
doesn't doesn't necessarily have to
you know make sense it's just like this
is just a funny thing to say yeah 100
you know 100 percent but you also want
to kind of find your voice and talk
about what's important yeah
um you do it this weekend
i was i went to jersey dude it's so
funny
i never been to jersey right
different
different yeah so we went to the what
was it um
that's a great deep fake
you look great there thanks man that
could be youtube i know
if you shaved your head i do shave your
head lifting weights you should you
shaved your head before all the time
yeah but you know people didn't like it
but dude you should get that big you
look awesome all right i will all right
chappelle oh
yeah so i was in jersey
and uh
my um toby my boy homie they were
playing a show in jersey and then
when they got done with the show we went
back to the hotel
and right across the street was this
wawa you heard of wawa's those
convenience stores they got food and
stuff
and
no one was really in there it was just
us and we were like ordering some food
and
like i said i've never been to jersey
and i didn't realize this
this lady the lady that was making our
food she goes
you guys aren't from around here and
we're like
how do you figure
she was like
you're really nice
and where in jersey was this i don't
even remember you know how old this is
like this moshing is hilarious that you
do this oh did i do this i'm living in
my life look at me
yeah
i just be doing [ __ ] another famous
community but it's like the same thing
just sent me this video this morning and
goes explain this
who keeps doing that not gonna tell you
who it is his name may may rhyme with ho
logan but that's it
no joe hates crowds like that he would
never do that so oh
like for joe and me like the idea of
being in a mosh pit with all those
people [ __ ] that but you got to realize
that's where i come from
yeah like i come from that world no i
mean that's hardcore that's a hardcore
yeah it's just energy
it's energy man it's not music it's
energy
i get i get it i mean we know just wait
what'd you say
how are you going to say that well no i
just mean there's no tempo or melody or
rhythm
what let's listen to it first hey no no
no no time out time on time out mile
timeout what what i say
play him show him dimebag daryl hold on
let me see you tell me yeah i listen but
may i listen to this i'm just saying let
me hear it let me know okay you can hear
it god
that's just here let me refresh this
real quick it's being the homie freddy
madball take it easy
shout out to my balls
[Music]
[Music]
it's not bad
there you go got some got some yeah
there's some form to it
i take it back bruh i take it back
let me show you toby's son
here chin i'm about to air drop you son
you told me this ain't music that was
good that'll kill a plant if you play it
if you play it next to a plant for life
it'll [ __ ] kill a plant
but who cares about your flowers will
wilt to that music but i'm not saying
you're talking all this [ __ ] no it
doesn't it doesn't necessarily like the
greeks used to play like certain tunes
to harmonize your body and that's
all this [ __ ] that that'll send you into
that'll give you a seizure if you listen
to it long enough well it'll kill you
because you won't sleep hold on man you
no but i mean i'm saying it's good if
you're
if you're
about to go fight if you're about to go
fight for your life that shit's good
brian right wouldn't you say is that
fair
i said to the chinese am i being fair am
i being unfair
listen
just watch listen kid's 19 years old
have you met john joseph from the crow
mags no i haven't met john joseph
they all it's one of my best like all
those dudes that i
you know was with that uh weekend they
all know they all come from the that's
my boy you gotta me you're gonna be john
he's the best he'd love you next time
you're in new york let me know and i'll
hook it up oh you will yeah oh you don't
think my buddies that i'm friends with
good oh yeah well john's one of my i'm
know john much better than all those
guys oh
much better man let me say it again hold
on it was much better but yeah oh much
better but
they they all came up together
understanding and the hardcore saying
better i better hear here just ask john
i like you know what say hey john brian
callan or those guys that's all i bet
you 500
that he would say those guys that's
adorable that are you sure you want to
do this you want to do 500
what you want hey you want to listen
last
35 years
really oh yeah about come on wait come
on now i can't wait i can't wait hi
although your boy i met he goes back
with him what's his name toby yeah oh
that's my boy okay that's that's a
difference so that's that's what i'm
talking about okay i'm not talking about
these two like people in the crowd way
back top is great that guy's my age
i think it's time i use young guys
tell me that's not [ __ ] good
[Music]
i can drum yeah
you tell me that's not a musician it's
it's it's definitely more energy it's
very energized sound it's a very there
it's a you can draw he can draw i would
call that i would call it directed sound
it's a it's i would call it i would call
it
i would call it
is the name of the band and i and i like
toby and he's a [ __ ] staple in the
hardcore scene so he's awesome but um my
guess is that that would be
less music and more
uh power energy
power sound power sound can we call it
power sound
you know i can name so many musicians of
the hardcore world that are amazingly
talented i'm not saying they're not
talented i'm not saying that i'm
musicians i'm saying that
is less what you would consider music
and more like
power energy power
and there's a technique to it and a
subculture right there's a technique too
it's a subculture it's less
technique yeah brian's talking about
different yeah there's a technique but
there's but it's it's is it's less
first of all
really really well
there's a technique
first of all you don't have to be a you
don't have to be an insanely skilled
musician to be a very successful
hardcore musician yes you do no you
don't yes you do
you have to hold on you're saying you
have to be a highly skilled musician
i'll name like 12 [ __ ] highly skilled
music doesn't mean that there are that
are in the heart doesn't mean there
aren't highly skilled musicians in the
hardcore world that doesn't mean that
what i'm saying is that you don't have
to be
a highly skilled okay
to make it very popular maybe back in
the day
now it's involved so it's so competitive
now it's evolved
all right i'm not hip on the hardcore
yeah so why are you judging it because
hardcore is is more energy than music
isn't it
it gets you amped it does yeah but
just don't there's a lot to do
or your dog might turn and bite you
right i mean wouldn't you say if you
want to get your dog that's super
friendly to bite you play that music no
listen to h2o it's different it's not
aggressive like that
it's different maybe h2s isn't hardcore
right
am i why are you being why are you gosh
why are you imagining everything to this
guy
but you
the thing is is like you judge [ __ ] that
you don't know
i'm not you're touching him you don't
know enough about oasis to judge oasis
you don't know enough about hardcore to
judge hardcore you're probably right i
don't know i don't know much about heart
i'm not gonna judge uh i don't know
nothing about jordan peterson
described it as energy you were like
you gave me props there is energy there
is all
but it's not just that i'm not dissing
it
i'm not saying it's just that i'm just
saying that overall hardcore you've
never seen mackie from the crowmag's
drum i've seen mackie drummond in person
yes i've met mackie many times
of course
yeah i have
i have i want to [ __ ] remember i am
of the generation where i kind of wear
hardcore
was an offshoot of sort of the british
punk scene right and so i am of that
generation i didn't know and see enough
of that okay gbs i saw those things i
was there
so like i was there when a lot of the
stuff was having its
it's so you know about cbgb's
i went to cbgb's
hey dude
hey dude
like who are you talking to i'm just
saying i'm 55 years old hey a lot of
people say [ __ ]
i was living on 11th avenue and 11th in
avenue a i would i would go to st
use on every way yes what do you know
about everything in nineteen years
what do they call avenue d back in the
day so they called it a you're
adventurous beer bold c you're crazy and
dear dead who are you
[Applause]
they all the italians lived there
in little italy in brooklyn that's where
my whole lineage is all right come on
all right come on
come on you win
you can't ask me these questions great
italian restaurants right in there yeah
again
and all of them
my gran my great-grandmother owned the
building that that [ __ ] uh what's the
clam house that where the the
guy was assassinated killed uh the [ __ ]
is his name yeah
wait um
[ __ ] i can't remember but but i i
mean yeah yeah yeah dude i i got my
roots there what year
it's [ __ ]
70s or 60s you know the mob was heavy
over there heavy heavy heavy heavy all
from the part of italy that my
grandfather was from
so when my grandfather
couldn't get in the reason his trucks
got in and the other trucks didn't was
because he was friends with all those
guys in the old country his father had
helped those guys when they came over
the bridge
so
my grandfather my grandfather every year
until he died every single year would be
a huge gift basket i mean a huge one
it'd be at the house and christmas
christmas
thanksgiving yeah
we would get uh easter we'd get this
massive [ __ ] you know fruit and nuts
and apples and all that [ __ ]
and
i was i remember one time the story was
that this one guy would send it every
[ __ ] year yeah why he was an italian
immigrant
he came into my grandfather's office my
grandfather had an import export company
and he made tomato sauce schlepfani yeah
still there my uncle just sold it it's
called scliffon it was pretty big it was
great tomatoes my grandfather was one of
the first people to start using to use
organic tomatoes the way they do in
italy he was like i wanted to stink i
want mike somebody was grown in [ __ ]
manure not in this other [ __ ] he didn't
trust these this [ __ ] he wanted to know
that's why scalphony tomato sauce was so
[ __ ] sick that's why i grew up he was
a maniac when it came to food okay so
this guy comes into his office one day
and he's he's an italian immigrant the
italians the sicilians the southerners
sicilians like in new york back then it
was exactly like mexicans like that's
why i have such a soft spot when i see
hard-working people from mexico yeah
from central america because it's a
similar kind of thing they they're tough
as [ __ ] this mentality of like yeah yeah
they it's just something i love about
that you know yeah any immigrant group
right
and
but the guy comes in
and he my fa my grandfather he was
selling uh
nuts like candied nuts that the guy was
obviously making at home he'd get buy
some sugar and he'd fry nuts on a pan
yeah and he had him and she's trying to
sell him my grandfather i love that
[ __ ] so much i i i'm so lucky to
have had him in my life but my sicilian
grandfather looked at him and they were
the guy was waving him off and my
grandfather said hold on i guess he
could tell by his eyes the guy was
desperate
my grandfather tried it and he goes
[ __ ] delicious
he bought the whole [ __ ] palette you
bought the whole thing you know
everybody had a [ __ ]
a big thing he was like
buy it for the office for the office
yeah yeah
his grandfather started it his father
had started so he'd take hit the four
brothers
so he bugging buys uh he buys it all
but he had a heart like that
he didn't need it all but he just [ __ ]
this i gotta let me make this guy's day
yeah buys it probably cost him 20 bucks
for the [ __ ] sword it was
this guy
ended up becoming a huge candy
nut
retailer
he ended up being a multi-millionaire
okay he made a fortune
the guy told my grandfather he sent him
a basket
like about i don't know five years later
what the [ __ ] it was never forgot him
and he came to the office with it and he
said to my grandfather i was gonna jump
off the brooklyn bridge i was gonna jump
off the bridge on my way back
but you bought you saved my life
you were my last stop
at the end of the day
and i couldn't take it anymore i was
gonna jump off the bridge
i just didn't have anything left and it
wasn't working [ __ ] and he had nothing
and he was going to jump off the [ __ ]
bridge but he my grandfather just you
know you do that as a human being yeah
it's like this other story about this
guy who just smiled at this he smiled at
this guy who was going to kill himself
yeah and then his smile like it just it
led to one thing after another right
[ __ ] someone spotted me one [ __ ]
yeah well that's why when you you you
just look at that but i never forgot
that story
because every [ __ ] year we'd get this
huge basket he never forgot my
girlfriend well he was sending stuff
every year for 40 years
he became a huge multi-millionaire i
mean i don't know if i can't remember
the story is great i don't know the
details yeah i never forgot that story
i like [ __ ] like that but every day huge
i mean every every holiday huge basket
from that guy you know what is well man
cool right yeah
so guys as many of you know um
french is uh
uh a
long jeep
okay i speak french
and you've gotta you can learn a
language
in 15 minutes a day you really can
and babel is a company where learning a
second language in high school like is
not going to work right and college
doesn't really work either but
babel is a language learning app it sold
over two
10 million subscriptions
it's addictively fun it's an easy way to
learn the new language
and it teaches you
in bite-sized language lessons that
you'll actually use in the real world
i've done
three different language things just to
stay fresh on my french but babel it's
got 15 minute lessons it makes it a
perfect way to learn you're your a lot
of the other language apps use ai for
their lesson plans
babel lessons are created by over a
hundred language experts so their
teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be effective
because they're real people
okay and you can choose 14 different
language including spanish french
italian and german
plus they've got speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and your accent all right
and they've also got all kinds of things
they got podcast games video stories
even live classes
um and it's a 20-day money-back
guarantee try it start looting and it's
a really good thing to do for your brain
too they actually
people who are prone to alzheimer's they
make you learn a new language apparently
so uh you know i i don't think you're
ever sorry for learning a new language
it's awesome you can save 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l-b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com fighter
for up to 60 off your subscription
babble
language for life
okay now listen
i have not
used real ketones i'm going to be honest
with you but i have seen firsthand how
well they work now here's what i mean
our boy brennan schaub who is in new
york right now promoting his special
um
gringo poppy
uh he uses real ketones
and it is it is a a very and it's an
advanced wellness technology it really
is
because it puts your body into ketosis
which is very very difficult to do okay
but it'll kick start your ability to
burn flat fat increase energy and
improve focus um and it's got zero sugar
it's got four essential electrolytes but
for a lot of scientific reasons which i
don't have to go into you get your body
into ketosis with this it it it really
is a very effective way to lose weight
it comes in six delicious flavors it's
got five grams of ketones and if you're
currently keto
it's you know i think brennan's still
keto but he still uses it because um it
has seven grams of ketones plus mct it's
a great complement to the keto lifestyle
i see him that's at least coming from
him and it really helps him with his
energy and his focus
um
so depending on what your wellness goals
are if you're trying to lose weight
you're trying to improve focus uh you
want more energy this could be the
product for you t5k listeners get 10 off
the site with a promo code shob
s-c-h-a-u-b
and if you don't absolutely love it
they'll give you your money back so head
to real ketones let's let me spell
ketones for you
k-e-t-o-n-e-s so it's real ketones dot
com slash
shob
use promo code shop for 10 off
i don't know what
like when i think about like work ethic
yeah you know especially when you speak
of you know
foreign people that come here and they
just work
so [ __ ] hard yeah in a way to where
it's like
like they show their level of
appreciation
by
for for where they're at yeah by just
[ __ ]
working yeah you know and like
no but it's different it's honest work
though right i'm just gonna say honest
work yeah honest work
and when i think about like
the society we kind of live in
you don't see that like so much you do
see it yeah not saying like no one no
one
in [ __ ] you know
america [ __ ] works their ass off yeah
people do but like it's just it just
seems so like
when you hear all these stories about
people coming you know from other
countries here you just hear like how
like it's just that's like the main
story desperation desperation a lot of
times you know what i mean yeah
desperation can breed success maybe
discomfort right yeah but i like you
know what i was thinking about the other
day is like
something about working with your hands
like a people that work with their hands
you ever notice how like so if i'm
around a dude who's made a fortune but
they've made a fortune in finance
you know they made a fortune in like
futures and options i don't know crypto
you know i i when i hear those things
when i hear like that that idea i'm
always like that that kind of person i
don't know i don't know if i trust that
person like i don't know enough about
how you make your money you might be
manipulating you might be it might be
one big lie it's like people that sell
certain products yeah like a lot of them
sounds like it's words and like whatever
maneuvering some way like i sell this
yeah this tincture i sell this thing mud
water i don't know i don't know i mean i
don't know what's in it i don't know
i don't know how much is marketing how
much is slick marketing that made your
company yeah right so it's like it's
like oh those are dope sneakers are they
good quality or are they just dope
sneakers are you are you really good at
selling the yeah yeah through your words
yeah how much is branding and versus
quality right but a plumber so so so not
to bring this up but none of you guys
these [ __ ] right yeah this
cured my feet okay yeah the reason that
i got i love toe hold the reason i love
these flip-flops is for me the guy ag
who makes these [ __ ] by hand he
uses he uses herman oak leather it's so
expensive and difficult to work with
it's top grain it's a part of the cow
that you use it's a part of the cow the
shoulder part that is the most durable
so you can step on this all day it still
smells like a [ __ ] horse
okay it's that kind of leather it's the
only product you can keep wearing and
looks better
as you wear it yeah it just gets better
right so but the the [ __ ] that the guy
made these the guy who started this
company
he he goes his flip-flops kept breaking
he was from san diego lived in
flip-flops so he goes [ __ ] this
my thong kept breaking so he finds
paracord that's not only 500 pound
strength whatever the [ __ ] but also
it it's it's woven so it it doesn't it
pushes debris out it doesn't collect it
and then he like he worked with a
japanese leather maker
and then he figured out what's the these
things are too hard so how do i make
them softer with vibram treads and he
all this engineering a tuck under design
see how they don't how these things
don't go around they they're tucked
under here i see those you'd never think
that would work that's how the japanese
did it so he studied that [ __ ] right
yeah and i've been when i watched this
[ __ ] make shoes he sent them to
me for free the minute i saw them
i go to him
he was hearing he listens to the podcast
factory
right
but he was listening to me talk about
how bad my feet were right so then i
start researching he goes you gotta wear
you gotta you gotta have zero drop
flip-flops and you gotta work your feet
then i find out this podiatrist this
this shoe doctor this this i mean the
shoe doctor goes uh foot doctor foot
doctor goes when you have shoes this for
anybody has bad feet okay anybody when
you wear shoes
okay so you got designer shoes all
designers what do they do they push your
toes to a point you ever notice that
here's the problem when you push your
toe
your big toe in
you cut off circulation to an artery in
your foot in a lot of cases not at all
but in a lot of cases when you do this
[ __ ]
that will cause the blood to stop
flowing to your heel you get necritis
that's what a lot of plantar fasciitis
is they're finding out it's not
inflammation okay and then because
you're cramped your feet then you get
what's called hammer toe where your toes
i just had two my boy sean reyes who's a
foot doctor came to my show in vegas he
and his buddy they came into my dressing
room and they took a massage they took
molds of me and max feet it's hilarious
they're making me do what they're making
me arch it they're making me uh insults
but we were talking you get hammer toes
your toes your toes so for style you
[ __ ] your feet up and then you can't
figure out why your toes at your feet
aren't getting better because you're
wearing shoes that are pulling your feet
together
so then
when you get a guy like like this guy
a.g who makes these shoes
and my feet get better there's something
honest
i am because my feet were [ __ ] i can't
wake up with problems he just i mean he
[ __ ] put his hand up
like your toes and like if you push like
this that's because that did all this
talking that [ __ ] ag he's a
maniac he sits in his he sits in vegas
don't lose your train of thought
you were trying to get to he's making
he's making [ __ ] with his hands yeah
okay
when i met him the the minute i met that
dude
i liked him and trusted him yeah because
he's a brown belt in jiu jitsu and when
he's not doing jiu jitsu he's [ __ ]
making flip-flops and he will not
compromise he doesn't like i'm i was
like you know i want to be involved in
the company okay and i'm like hey let's
make them cheaper let's use this
material he goes that's never happening
never happening he will only use the
best leather like they dye it with
vegetable roots and leaves the old
fashioned color yeah that's how you get
like you know saddle leather or the kind
of leather that um
that [ __ ] hermes does with their bags
i'm not the most expensive leather in
the world oh god okay it's made the
old-fashioned way they actually
dye it with organic they
ground roots and and and leaves like
certain roots and leaves they grind that
[ __ ] this guy from here he's from san
diego originally but he lives in vegas
what's this like i went to a shop
he just woke him wanted to make well
dude i'm obsessed with they they cured
my feet i'm obsessed with those
flip-flops i know you wear them all the
time the only thing i wear
you wear it's it's it was the only thing
that felt i'm not in the fashion this is
the only thing i felt honestly oh we
know you're not in the fashion
but the the kind of designs that that
you know they're coming up with like
dragon go to go to um go to touhou to
instagram and look at these these
[ __ ] i mean you're not into
flip-flops but
i'm obsessed i know that's why i left
this school because it's honest right
there
i i mean i respect that it's obvious but
look at look at look at these things
look at the shitty mix
look at those silver ones
this one yeah look at that [ __ ] come on
man
i mean my music shop and you guys are
not into this [ __ ] i'm upset
all right let's get out
i'm making about work ethic dude is is
the fact that there's something about
people that work with their hands and
craft [ __ ] yes artisans yes where i can
see where you're making carpenters
leather workers all that [ __ ] people who
designed that let's get that off what is
that
that's just one of the toho girls
but but you see what i'm saying like
when i see people do that when they like
you know those guys who make benchmade
shoes benchmade knives
yeah
i don't actually well you can't lie
i i try to say i do
to but i was like damn it i can't i
don't like to lie so there's a there's a
coffee place in l.a called cafe luxe
l-u-x-x-e
it's the best coffee in the world but
those two guys who own it they're
maniacs where is that you want they
won't even let you pull malibu yeah they
won't even let you pull their coffee for
long like you get your like you get the
espresso the way they say you're gonna
get it but dude it's the best coffee in
the world you don't get better coffee
than that you don't you just don't
as i've been getting better about
drinking
coffee i do appreciate
the way people have it down to a science
like the way coffee places like have it
down yeah and you i do i do like that
the only way you you do
i do the espresso the little espresso
which is
in italy that's the way they [ __ ] do
it they don't do
and the way they came up with the
americano
was because some americans came to
italy got an espresso that's right and
they were like
where's the rest of the drink
you know because it was just too little
so they put hot water in it so they just
would they just added water in it but it
makes that total sense yeah and that's
how they came up with them and that's
why i call it americano i love it i love
it
you didn't know that no
it makes sense though yeah yeah if i
heard it from a barista when i was at a
hotel i believe it because in italy when
you go to like naples yeah everybody has
a tiny cup
and you just it takes you it's literally
a shot you just go and you go yeah so
you sit that's like really really strong
right but but they put some sugar in it
because but it's like a bitter
not when you have the right so earth
cafe has amazing espresso okay italian
espresso and uh and so does cafe lux
amazing espresso and so does two guns
dos pizzas
that
that [ __ ] is sweet that's where's two
guns
it tastes the way it smells yeah
yeah
so anyways back at work ethic
yeah so my point is like why is it that
i trust people that work with their
hands like my boy g no that makes sense
and then a dude who's like maybe it's i
don't understand finance
i don't know or maybe they just don't
have any time to like
you can't like no you don't have time
for [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah maybe you work with
your hands like that's what you do and
like you have to like you just do but
maybe it comes i'm not saying like
finance we were a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
but like you don't have to you know what
i'm trying to say someone help me out
well there's [ __ ] there's a lot of
[ __ ] in finance yeah there's a lot of
[ __ ] like being a plumber like you're
a [ __ ]
plumber you're fixing a toilet whatever
blah blah like you know carpenter yeah
but
like like like on on average i would
imagine if i said to you he's a
carpenter or he's a he's a leather
craftsman yeah and then i said he's a
financier
chances are you're going to probably
trust the fight the craftsman
there's something about it yeah i don't
know like yeah the financier sounds like
[ __ ] i don't dude
how much is all my money yeah i respect
like construction workers yeah i
remember um when i was in high school
build houses yeah when i was in high
school one of my home girls that i
cheered with her dad owned a
construction company and during the
summer i would work work for him you
know i wasn't like [ __ ] building [ __ ]
but yeah you know i would help the guy i
would like lift the damn
plywood all this stuff and you know
whatever they needed i would you know
assist with you know
um but
watching what they do
is like
i saw that insane i respect construction
workers so much because yeah that [ __ ]
especially especially doing construction
in arizona oh [ __ ] but dude i went to is
fun
sorry it's [ __ ] insane
like
i went to england and my buddy's mate
building a house that's like i don't
know i don't know what is it 30 million
dollars i don't even know what the [ __ ]
this is about it it's the craziest house
i've ever seen yeah
and he's got craftsman
stone cr men who work with stone that he
flew in from portugal you know like
they're like six people that know how to
build
a uh um a [ __ ]
house the way they did in the 1500s yeah
you know the guys that know how to work
with slate you have a slate specialist a
granite specialist is just people who
build uh massive beams out of reclaimed
wood that they find like like
uh i don't know uh they they find
old
railroad tracks that were made from
redwoods that were cut down in the
1800s that kind of wood that will never
so your homie wants a house like that
he's already built it
yeah he built it and let me tell you
it's but is it like modern oh dude no no
i'm glad you asked no in fact
in fact
he's got an herb garden but it's massive
when you when you look at the house in
person
well it looks like it's
300 years old really yes and that's why
you pay that much i was like that's not
300 years old like how was it just made
now now
don't have
40 some really rich guy already offered
him i think 60 million dollars to buy it
to the 60 mil yeah
for that and the property around it he
said he's like he's like that dumb money
not for sale
yeah i mean come on
took three years to build he has it in
london it's on the outskirts took him
three years to build
three years to build a house but i mean
like you had you got specialists from
all over those people those craftsmen
those people that that understand that
kind of that artisanship that [ __ ]
that's been passed down from generation
yeah yeah like you have to study like
when you i honestly didn't know they
were still doing when you when you are a
when you are a builder like a contractor
in france for example um
especially like i was looking at this in
france if you build a house in france
the people that build that house the
schooling the education they have to be
able to build that oh dude the guy's in
charge of the entire project the
education is every bit as intricate and
as deep as some of the brain surgeons
every bit so you can't just do that oh
[ __ ] no yeah [ __ ] no you don't have
shoddy construction those [ __ ]
are like that's
that's it
that shit's it
that's
a special type of person to [ __ ] i
envy it sort of yeah that's why i said i
respect
construction workers yeah because
i don't ever want to do it again oh no
it's [ __ ] the hard labor far it's
but when you do it in europe a lot of
times it's an apprenticeship
so you got to understand how to cut
stone you always understand how to lay a
pipe it's an art you have to understand
how to build a house from the ground up
perfectly
because think about all the moving parts
yeah
you know they always used to like in
like writing a great script to building
a house because structure
foundation
and then all the piping and all this
stuff is so important that's why nobody
writes that's why 10 people can write a
script in hollywood there are actually
10 people that can actually write the
x-rated x-ray yeah like 10 good writers
i believe that isn't that crazy i boo i
totally believe that
i 100 believe that
[ __ ] nuts because when i was reading
that damn thing i was like
how the [ __ ] did they write this i know
it's [ __ ] crazy i know i'm like what
i can't wait to hear who it is oh yeah
i'll tell you
i'll tell you off here what do you got
jen we got to get up we got to get
chappelle all right sounds good oh
how you doing buddy i'm doing good you
gotta we gotta
oh so this is a little update with the
amber her johnny depp situation now that
the case is and the trial is ongoing
there has been a very large petition
amongst uh comic book fans just people
in general
get her out get her out of aquaman too
jason mamoa actually also was trying to
get her out and
has he said that oh yes he's like he's
been very open yeah yeah like supports
johnny depp through and through i love
this song how [ __ ] crazy you can't
cancel advice both ways [ __ ] you
lie about people and it's what happens
i'm [ __ ] you and is this what she's
famous for the aquaman's uh no i would
say that's the most recent big thing
she's done but she's worked in hollywood
for quite some time not the biggest star
ever but she definitely had it that's
what i thought because i've never really
heard of her until
the trial yeah have you ever seen her
never back down
yeah yeah she's the she's the girl on
the show
yes
but people are saying behind the scenes
that aquaman two only has ten minutes of
her
which is crazy because i think she is a
principal character in the uh that's
right they're editing the [ __ ] out of
her yeah they're re-editing it
and it's set to be released i believe
march 2023 so we don't know yeah
is even gonna be in it i hate seeing the
destruction of anybody but this i'm
enjoying this absolutely oh my god
terrible i think she's a liar she
hijacked the movement to make herself
look better and she used her vic
womanhood to play a victim and that this
is the kind of [ __ ] that you get and i
love justice it's so i wish there were
more cases
[Music]
i saw an article about her earlier today
on my way into work where i guess she
had fired her entire pr team because of
all of she isn't enjoying the bad press
she's getting and she's so stressed that
she fired them all in the middle of this
case so it's only gonna go downhill from
here yeah
in today's world and what they made the
mistake of was they put that
[ __ ] there's a reason johnny
depp is a one of the biggest movie stars
ever you get that guy up on a stand
he takes ten minutes to say one sentence
but man
i can't take my dude
he's got us he's got
a great sense of humor yeah
everything he does and he barely lifts
his voice yeah does he barely barely
leave his mouth
how crazy was that i don't know if you
heard the uh one of the recordings that
he recorded where he was talking about
like her punching him mm-hmm and she
basically was like
i wasn't punching you i was hitting you
you don't know the difference i mean
i'm sitting here like oh this is [ __ ]
like
what i 100 believe him 100 percent
everybody in his life everybody's like
yeah now we've never seen him do that
and she's an [ __ ] which you can just
see i mean i just i've been in this i
wanted to like work with her on set like
have had like a history of
like well no on set
see these people are are these people
are very good at seducing we gotta
remember amber people like this are are
master hypnotists and seductresses yeah
they're man this is men and women i'm
not this is not a bachelorette it's not
bash on women or women actresses i'm
talking about there are people if
they're really good at acting they can
manipulate they can like their master
manipulators you'll fall in love with
that person right up right that's that's
yeah that's voodoo [ __ ] but but um
but it it's really the question of
talk to their assistants talk to the
people about the people that work with
them like talk to johnny depp yeah
people in their life that is fair and uh
and when they see an opportunity
because they're such narcissists
that there's it's just all about them
all the time you will see people like
this like like amber they only date
really famous people why because it
brings more attention to them
there is an endless need for attention
it will never go away yeah
did you see that psychiatrist break down
her [ __ ] beautiful disorder it was
beautiful and she's gorgeous and
smartest [ __ ]
i love it right
because there are a lot of women that
can't stand this this [ __ ] yeah they
can't
a lot of women couldn't say it before
but they were like watching a lot of
people that they were worried about
their husbands and their sons and their
brothers
and they were like this is out of
control because women know women know
more about women than men do and women
know that women believe all women except
for who just lane maxwell amber heard
and and that woman from theranos got a
couple of other other people you want to
talk about
it's like what do you mean believe all
women believe don't believe all people
yeah men and women lie [ __ ] men
and women lie a lot
it's one thing my lawyer said
i had a thing and i was like but i
this didn't happen and he goes
we were talking about somebody
i did there was a thing and i go but
they know the truth here
and he goes i know but people lie brian
when you're a lawyer like me people lie
yeah and that's how it is
yeah that was almost decorated a lie
it's okay it's like here this is what
we're going to say
anything like this because it's easier
it's like i can't
yeah anyway all right i do like that
jacket by the way side note
jack i like you or whatever i don't know
what it looks like it's a great [ __ ]
outfit thank you i like it
before i forget before we go on guys i
need a videographer for new york
you got a guy
you sure yeah well all right reach out
to me if you're a good videographer uh
this weekend in new york me and joey
diaz
um
newark i'm gonna be doing something at
the stress factory and i want to shoot
some footage i need somebody to help me
shoot some footage for something i'm
doing this new project i have if you're
a good videographer hit me up i'll be in
new york starting thursday this thursday
friday saturday stress factory hit me at
briancallen gmail.com
all right bam all right here we go so
this one's kind of a sad one vanessa
bryant had posted a tribute to her
daughter uh gianna because it was her
16th birthday i believe nike is doing
something where they created a shoe
specifically for her and all the
proceeds will then go to like a
a charity that helps women trying to
play basketball or in sports something
along those lines because she was a huge
advocate for
uh
women playing sports and having that be
at the forefront of what she wanted to
do yeah as she got older yes
she wanted to win a championship in the
uh wnba
unfortunately heavy heavy [ __ ] man happy
[ __ ]
so [ __ ]
heavy hmm
next one i should watch this she was she
was the
she wasn't the the oldest right or was
she i believe she was the one she's the
oldest daughter she was the one that
kobe yeah she was the one that kobe had
like his sights on for like she's going
to carry my legacy yeah basketball yeah
and that baby wasn't even one when he
passed right
it was like march
that's beyond yeah somebody with a
daughter that age man i can tell you
yeah
so uh
tweets between aoc and elon musk were
going viral because she had made a
subtweet about a egotistical billionaire
on twitter and he then responded by
saying stop uh hitting on me i'm really
shy
which is funny because she came back
with a response saying oh i'm actually
talking about mark zuckerberg
and not him so they were just having
like a good like back and forth hold on
this is great
alc would say this she's so out of touch
tired of having collectively to
collectively stress about what explosion
of hate crimes is happening because some
billionaire with an ego problem
unilaterally controls a massive
communication platform and skews it
because tucker carlson or peter thiel
took him to dinner and made him feel
special
uh
stop hitting on me i'm really shy yes
yes she responds like i said ego
problems oh this is good they're going
to be dating in no time
i was i was talking about zuckerberg but
okay
yeah it's just a funny little back and
forth good for her she's good wait she's
joking around yeah she's joking you
deleted the tweet which was epic hold on
i try to avoid giving people with
massive evil complexes like this the
attention and qt's replies they crave
and are seeking when i can help it
all right it's good just a fun little
thing thanks for having fun yeah good
for her
i don't mind this is the american that's
the american thing
let's have fun yeah so olivia wilde was
at cinemacon and she was presenting her
film she's making her
second movie uh directorial not debut
because she made one already but this
film is gonna be huge for her and her
career when she was presenting the film
someone went up to her while she's
talking on stage and presents her with a
manila envelope that says uh
confidential and personal yeah so i
guess she got served papers over a
custody battle with her ex-husband jason
sedakis while she was presenting what
the [ __ ] and people are saying that it's
a very
and i believe the reason why this
happened during
this uh presentation was because she
actually left jason sedakis and started
dating harry styles who was the star of
her film so i think this all kind of
ties into
each other and why he's being petty
about it because it's a very specific
timing when he oh that's what it is
decided to surf her papers what the [ __ ]
who is that yeah what his wife is this
is something else this girl's like part
of the article isn't it though very
pretty very pretty
just some bar stool girls jesus i'll
just be yeah wait so that's crazy dude
yeah she she
she left him yeah she left him she
started dating harry styles which is a a
he's like 20 something right yeah
he was in one direction he is a very
handsome man you know i'm brian he's a
big big star in the
music world he showed up in a dress
how old is he
uh a little older than me i want to say
20 come on maybe my age 28 20 6 20 and
how old is how old is this hey how does
olivia walk olivia i want to see in her
late 30s if not early 40s she's an older
woman he's 28 28. and uh she's let's see
oh she's thirty-eight right ten years
ten year difference i'm a senior
okay
okay ain't no wrong with that what you
don't like that no i i don't say that at
all i'm just saying yeah what are you
saying okay foreign now this is her
third marriage
i don't know she's not married to
harry styles they're just dating
then she had two kids with siddiques
how long was she married to jason
for a while i had to have two kids i
don't know if they hit a decade but it
was definitely
wow
a fairly long relationship in hollywood
standards
well sometimes
when it hits you it hits you nine years
later
yeah okay yeah wow you're probably not
in love anymore nine years alone hey
good run i'm not gonna be fine nine
years is good success in hollywood
standards plus they are like nine years
old so much time apart yeah you know
that's the other thing about being
married in hollywood you're not really
you grow apart you're not that then now
you're with some [ __ ] awesome guy
like harry styles is probably like
charismatic as [ __ ] smart as [ __ ] and oh
by the way he can sing
what are you gonna do you're [ __ ] how
long i think that'll last for
how long you been together i think i i i
know i think when you're when you're a
star on that level what happens is you
get lonely as [ __ ] what the truth is
that when you're jason sedakis or you're
olivia wilde and you're really famous at
the top of your yeah you have no time
you live on a set and you get lonely
you get so [ __ ] lonely and you're how
many times can you face time with the
man you're married to the woman you're
married to yeah how many times can you
you're never seeing them um and you're
trying to do this thing and then you're
around incredible people i guarantee you
harry styles will could [ __ ] everybody
in this room including the straight guys
you know what i mean like there's some
people that are that they're that
charismatic you just you're around them
and you're like this guy's [ __ ] great
and brian's a trip yeah but you know
what i mean like and and so now she's
there they're spending time one they're
drinking wine one thing leads to another
and you're [ __ ] chappelle if you get
this table read
you're gonna know exactly what brian's
talking about but nine years man hats
off to both of them that's no joke
that's a good run sedega seems like a
great guy yeah and he's doing fine too
he's out dating it's like yeah he's
doing this
it is a bummer how it all came out
because i think people found out that
she was dating harry styles and then the
separation news came out so they found
out before anything was announced
made him look kind of bad i don't judge
anybody for
i'm no one no
las vegas nobody wise guys comedy club
april 28th you already went there sorry
sorry uh i just did that thank you las
vegas
dude
hold on i had to refresh let's hear it
no there you go there you go my bad bro
[ __ ] i've been doing the road so much
this next eight weeks in a row i got
stress factory new brunswick uh i got
uh joey diaz is gonna be um
a special guest on for that whole
weekend i'm so excited stress factory
this weekend starting thursday friday
saturday i got the comedy loft dc comedy
loft uh may 12 13 14. then i got my
special taping special taping bray
improv thursday may 19th two shows get
your tickets
west palm beach after that
um may 27 28 29
then i got
talia's opening for me at the brand
problem i might have another special
guest we'll see
did you wait you always said are you all
done sir okay okay
uh this weekend actually i'll be in san
diego may 6th and 7th at mike drop
comedy club and then next week i'll be
doing a one-nighter in the hometown
phoenix at uh stand up live and then in
the summertime june 24th the 25th i'll
be in rhode island at the comedy
connection
and one more thing yeah what uh we have
yeah yep me
chappelle his band mad peaceful little
brows we're doing a concert at the
troubadour in l.a yeah oh wait on may
17th tuesday brian if you can make it
though you guys are going to be there
yeah and plus
i'm [ __ ] that'd be amazing and if you
say my music game music i swear to god
wait you're both playing yeah we're
playing tribute you think i'm not going
to be there of course oh yeah bro that's
amazing where
dude i'm going to be able to use the
game i'm going to be in the mosh pit
freaking the [ __ ] out say my music ain't
music and i'm going to drop kick you in
that damn fit
i'm not saying it's not music i'm saying
your music and little brother
so all you [ __ ] yeah we're
doing it i can't believe it in l.a so
i know you want to know what i'll do i
swear to god i'll sell [ __ ] merch for
you and i'm not joking shut up
you're not joking i will do it i think
you would if you could
say if you want to meet me i swear to
god i'm going if you want to beat me
i'll sell
i'll be there it'd be hilarious for me
to sell merch
so funny i'm not joking i'm going to be
okay all right that's pretty much it all
right that's it i'm excited
remind me i'm dead 100 percent yeah
thanks brian yeah that'll be [ __ ]
great big bro
all right
um yeah that's it
see you guys